à l'époque vous vous parlez avec lui une
fois que vous êtes parti du Mexique vous
téléphonez à ce moment-là plusieurs fois
par jour au téléphone on avait de très
bonnes relations
Maud Versini bonsoir
alors mode version
au début des années 2000 vous vivez une
belle histoire d'amour avec Arthur au
Montiel gouverneur de l'état de Mexico
au Mexique l'un des hommes les plus
puissants du pays quelques années plus
tard vous êtes marié avec Arthur Montiel
vous avez trois enfants et il brille la
présidence de la République du Mexique
mais l'histoire tourne au cauchemars il
y a deux ans vos enfants sont enlevés
par leur père vous ne les avez pas revu
depuis cela fait
773 jours aujourd'hui vous nous
raconterez votre histoire à 20h
[Musique]
mode vers finit rebonsoir
vous êtes né à Neuilly le 9 janvier
1974 père administrateur de société mère
femme au foyer vous avez trois frères et
sœurs vous grandissez à Paris et après
votre bac et une école de commerce vous
travaillez dans l'immobilier et puis au
début des années 2000 vous entamez une
nouvelle activité faites des publières
portages à l'étranger pour une société
de presse première destination le
Mexique vous devez interviewer des
grands entrepreneurs des banquiers des
hommes politiques et c'est comme ça que
vous rencontrez Arturo Montiel à
l'époque Arthur Montiel est l'un des
hommes les plus influents du Mexique
figure montante du PRI le parti
révolutionnaire institutionnel qui est
le premier parti du Mexique il est
gouverneur de l'état de Mexico qui est
le premier état du Mexique et qui est
généralement pour les hommes politiques
là-bas un tre mplin pour la présidence
vous avez 26 ans il a 56 ans il est en
train de se séparer de sa première femme
avec qui il a eu deux fils alors tout de
suite Arturo vous aide pour votre
mission et vous vous ouvrez porte
il m'introduit auprès des gouverneurs
locaux auprès des entrepreneurs dans son
état surtout
et au bout d'un an votre relation
dirons-nous à dépasser le cadre
professionnel
si on veut alors vous installez au
Mexique à l'époque vous avez quand même
des sentiments un peu mitigés je le
connais pas très bien
j'ai jamais vu vraiment passé de temps
avec lui j'ai peur de m'investir avec un
homme qui n'était pas encore divorcé à
l'époque prétendait de séparé depuis 7
ans mais je ne savais pas là j'avais pas
la certitude de ce qu'il m'avançait et
donc j'ai pris la décision de le
connaître un peu plus j'ai commencé un
travail sur place
indépendante vous avez un job vous avez
un appartement et quelques mois plus
tard votre histoire devient officielle
au Mexique tout à fait là lors d'une
visite à Paris vous demande en mariage
sous l'Arc de Triomphe
le 22 juin 2002 vous devenez
officiellement la première dame du
premier état du Mexique alors c'est pas
rien d'être première dame d'un état
là-bas parce que d'office vous prenez la
tête du ministère des affaires sociales
vous dirigez 700 personnes et vous
passez votre temps à faire des
inaugurations des conférences de presse
enfin c'est pas rien comme boulot
et vous dites c'est plus belles années
de ma vie alors au départ c'est un
mariage assez heureux vous avez trois
enfants avec Arturo tout va bien en 2005
la pré campagne présidentielle démarre
au Mexique et Arthur romantiel et le
mieux placé pour être le candidat
officiel du parti révolutionnaire
institutionnel à la présidence alors
c'est quelqu'un d'assez dur vous êtes un
peu son intouchables on a tout cœur
alors dans l'intimité Arturo c'est
plutôt un papa old school c'est à dire
qu'il prend pas les enfants dans ses
bras
il change pas les couches non pas du
tout
malheureusement il y a plus grave il
boit pas mal
il a l'alcool mauvais en plus oui
[Musique]
fin 2005 Arthur remonte elle est
quasiment choisi par le PRI pour être
candidat officiel à la présidentielle et
c'est là
que son adversaire principal un dénommé
madrasso
l'accuse de corruption dans une émission
de télévision il prouve qu'a
cartourementiel a détournée 200 millions
de dollars il comprend que c'est la fin
de sa carrière politique je pense que ce
soir là il a compris
là ils sombres dans la dépression et
l'alcool
en 2007
vous décidez de le quitter il cherche
pas à vous retenir en fait ni vous ni
les enfants il est convaincu que vous
allez revenir
et que ça allait me passer
vous rentrez à Paris
et là vous menez une vie assez simple
loin des nounous des des gardes du corps
des chauffeurs vous retrouvez une vie
normale ça vous fait du bien
à l'époque vous vous parlez avec lui une
fois que vous êtes parti du Mexique vous
téléphonez à ce moment-là plusieurs fois
par jour au téléphone on avait une très
bonne très bonne relation alors le
divorce c'est prononcé en 2007 vous
obtenez la garde des enfants vous devez
simplement les envoyer au Mexique ce qui
sont normales pour Noël et puis pour les
vacances
par ailleurs vous rencontrez à ce
moment-là un autre homme avec qui vous
avez une petite fille et vous pensez que
les choses sont rentrées dans l'ordre à
ce moment-là quatre ans ont passé
effectivement tout allait bien
mais peu de temps après à tout
remontentiel vous propose de vous
envoyer des nounou mexicaines chez vous
il trouvait que les enfants perdaient un
peu leur espagnol quand ils les avaient
au téléphone ou quand ils venait au
Mexique le voir et il trouvait aussi que
d'un point de vue logistique c'était
plus simple que les enfants quand ils
venaient au Mexique soient accompagnés
par ces jeunes filles mexicaines
malheureusement c'est nounou sont là
pour fabriquer des faux témoignages
et deux d'entre elles portent plainte
pour maltraitance exactement des
aberrations sur notre manière d'élever
les enfants à la maison
l'enquête est classée sans suite comme
il y a pas de maltraitance
le 15 décembre 2011 comme chaque année
vous organisez un repas de Noël avant
que vos trois premiers enfants partent
pour le Mexique c'est cela vous faites
une photo
vous ne savez pas que c'est la dernière
fois que vous voyez les trois grands qui
ont donc 7 ans pour les jumeaux et 6 ans
pour le petit
les enfants partent le 16 ils doivent
rentrer le 2 janvier mais le 1er janvier
à tout remonter vous appelle et vous dit
les enfants ne rentreront jamais en
France je me suis écroulée
tu ne les reverras plus jamais en France
mais tu peux venir quand tu veux les
voir au Mexique et pourquoi a-t-il fait
ça parce que je l'ai quitté parce que je
me suis remarié parce que j'ai refait ma
vie parce que je suis ressens lui
alors dans un premier temps vous gagnez
vos procès évidemment
en juillet 2012 il y a un nouveau
président qui est élu au Mexique qui
s'appelle Enrique Peña Nieto qui est le
cousin d'Arturo mon tiède et en fait
c'est Arturo qui l'a fait mentor et à
partir de là l'attitude de la justice
mexicaine change considérablement ils
sont contre vous et alors que j'avais
gagné effectivement tous mes procès je
n'ai fait que perdre j'ai tout perdu on
a recommencé à zéro le procès et là tout
s'est écroulé j'ai compris que il avait
complètement acheté la justice de son
état et on fait croire effectivement que
j'allais pouvoir récupérer les enfants
jusqu'au jour où voilà il a été élu et
j'ai perdu mes process tôt ce sont des
enfants dont les droits sont bafoués la
convention internationale de la haie
violée et surtout je n'ai pas le droit
d'accès à mes enfants justement ça fait
773 jours que vous n'avez pas vu vos
enfants vouloir parler au téléphone une
fois par mois mais il peut se passer
deux mois sans qu'on voulait pas alors
au tout départ les enfants étaient très
aimables très gentil
adorable en me disant qu'il m'aimait que
je leur manquait aujourd'hui
cette atroce aujourd'hui ce sont des
enfants qui se sont transformés
ce qu'on appelle l'aliénation parentale
ils sont programmés sont conditionnés
manipulés on leur dit des atrocités sur
moi donc forcément les enfants c'est des
enfants
alors quand vous allez au Mexique et
vous étiez allé douce fois vous
n'arrivez pas à les voir parce que
là-bas tout le monde a peur de votre
ex-mari et quand vous allez à l'école
pour les voir soit vous êtes refoulé
soit vous êtes obligé de rester devant
les grilles de l'école
je suis allée plusieurs fois à l'école
la première fois j'ai réussi à rentrer
un sensibiliser le directeur pour lui
expliquer que j'avais gagné mon procès à
l'époque qu'il fallait qu'il me laisse
voir mes enfants il a refusé il m'a dit
que celui qui payait l'école c'était le
père et que il y avait tous les droits
la deuxième fois je suis retournée j'ai
croisé un de mes enfants dans un couloir
de l'école je lui ai couru après et je
me suis fait barrer la route par une
maîtresse
qui m'a fermé la porte au nez qui m'a
dit qu'elle ne me connaissait pas et
qu'il fallait que je dégage ce que je
trouve de plus cruel dans notre histoire
c'est quand vous allez là-bas on vous
dit vous allez les voir pendant deux ans
j'ai demandé un droit de visite qui m'a
été refusé au bout de deux ans la juge a
accédé à ma requête et m'a donné deux
heures pour un rendez-vous dans un
centre de médiation la première fois
c'était en septembre je suis allée avec
des sacs chargés de cadeaux de jouets de
jeux de photos
j'ai attendu ils sont pas venus j'ai eu
un deuxième rendez-vous de deux heures
le 16 décembre je me suis présenté à
nouveau on m'avait dit vous êtes ça
c'est sûr le consul général de la
Béziers ils vont venir c'est obligé
ils ne sont pas venus
le pire c'est que le petit dernier
souffre d'un trouble autistique
ce sont des enfants qui me grondiront
plus jamais comme les enfants normaux
qui sont des enfants qui ne seront plus
jamais stables plus jamais équilibrées
toute leur vie je ne comprends pas
je ne comprends pas l'attitude du père
ça me dépasse un monstre
merci de votre témoignage
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu